c'est très contente de travailler avec
vous c'est votre service n'a rien à se
reprocher tout ira bien comme les
cerveaux que je n'ai pas peur de la
police des polices après que ça va faire
avancer les choses
ça y est là toutes les deux à remuer
tout ça virginie ben ammar el naïve elle
même un peu dire je pense qu'elle a
compris des choses mais quand vous
passez la bonne comme vous savez les
deux femmes qui viennent de chez vous
arrive pas à l'éternel comportement
privé contraire un leak de la police qui
a un bon dossier vous voulez savoir
c'est ça j'aime regarder les gens en
dessous chics roskosmos
[Musique]
quoi qu'on aille mais 17 ans
salif dans cette affaire je faisais fini
les piscines et les 6 2
l histoire n
j'aime parler mais j'aime le silence
aussi